[Music]
we had mark Normand yeah who's a heckler
and everybody went along with you people
accepted that I think there's a little
bit of poetry in that at least those are
great shoes what are those thanks man
these are a echo echo i don't know echo
echo it's like they're kind of like old
people's shoes all right it's just
they're just made for comfort yeah
that's like that or anything yeah I have
bad feet so I have New Balance which I
think of the most compass shows and then
I put a New Balance insole inside that
just for an extra wow what are you gonna
get sponsored by then I'm trying jeez I
would love that although they were uh
then what is it neo-nazis just I mean
they were like the shoe of the neo-nazi
which is kind of a bummer it's true I
know you had the penguin sponsorship
though yes
so wow you're good Oh how'd you know
about that here's what Colbert right
yeah jeez you killed it
what how did you get that are we on we
are on oh [ __ ] I had no idea podcaster a
podcaster here alright man I didn't know
about the come guzzling Nazi does that
make it in we can take it out that's
fine my offensive Nazis and some come
guzzlers but hey uh yeah Colbert I was
said I was I posted a whole post like
hey I've known Colbert and Penguins saw
it and they said hey if you wear a suit
we'll give it to you for free and we'll
give you some extra clothes so I said
alright they hit you up they hit me up
and I never bought a suit in my life and
it was like a crazy baby blue suit which
I would have not have chosen but it kind
of worked so yeah it looks great too man
oh thanks you did great ah connected to
like opening for Amy Schumer if you get
all these endorsement deals now I wish
I'm doing theater arenas with her with
10,000 people each night so I feel like
cake come on if you want to make some
some eyeballs on these clothing yeah you
know this is the right guy but I never
got a head up this isn't this is a dope
time to be interviewing you you've been
touring around doing arenas and
everything the first time we talked I
guess when you were here opening for Amy
at Phillips Arena and we talked about
doing a phone interview but I wanted to
face-to-face with more because I know
you hate eye contact big so want to make
sure you were as uncomfortable as
possible I'm on come with eye contact
also with your use of the word dope that
came out of nowhere
coming from somebody who said come
guzzling not seeing mm-hmm that's that's
a compliment
yes I just feel weird using anything
that's hip because I don't know hip
stuff makes me very uncomfortable
because it feels it's just such a time
stamp on it like it's like saying groovy
and then you look back and go boy how
weird is that they said groovy what a
bunch of weirdos I said far-out come on
it's like if you like the phrase why
didn't why don't you still use far-out
yeah I'm saying this is like the same
with dope I feel like in 10 years there
was gonna go could you believe he said
dope I don't know I I worry about that
that's why don't wear cool clothes
because I'm so worried about you know if
you like it do it forever
yeah some kids like hey I love Snoop
Dogg and then you go you meet him in
when he's forward you go why you like
Snoop Dogg he goes I was a kid well you
can still making a decent choice just
making any sense
absolutely all right you just let new
rambles yeah no you're doing great buddy
when I was a kid I liked green - to like
read a mm-hmm I don't get why people you
know if you like something I don't feel
like you should like something just cuz
it's hip to me that's very sheepish
right you just following the the pack
yeah that's all I'm saying but you're on
the fast track you started opening for
Amy just like two years into your comedy
career right yeah yeah I guess so it was
fast like you had a big very lucky and
pure look I was doing a show I was
bombing at this club called comics which
is no longer there with an ex
and I was bombing one joke worked and
she happened to walk in on that one joke
oh wow she came in the green one said
hey that was fun I feel like we'd have a
good rapport and I kind of thought she
might have been hitting on me and she
goes you want to do Hofstra which is a
college and I didn't know that and I was
like yeah I just said yes and then we
did that and that was it and now you're
doing arenas yeah yeah it's amazing what
is it what have you learned from kind of
seeing her grow into this machine like
its industry now she's a monster I mean
I watched her do a Hartford funnybone
with you know 28 people then I watch her
doing a theater with a thousand people
and that was insane and then I watched
her do arena I mean I just learned that
she just knew she was driven she was
like I'm I know I'm good when is the
world gonna catch on I think and they
did they caught on and she never was she
never buckled you know like she got the
roast that was the roast for Charlie
Sheen was looking big that was a big
break for her and she was like I'm ready
bring it on I would have been like oh my
god this roast freaking out but she
never had that mm-hmm she was like let's
just do it let's come on let's get it
over with and then we'll do the next
thing which I don't have I have a conan
coming up when I'm already I've done it
four times I'm already nervous about it
how long until that a few months I got a
while so you you prepped though like
what is the prep for when you do a conan
oh my god well first you have to send
him a tape and then he approves what
jokes he likes then you go over the
order of the joke so it's a it's a long
process and then you might write a new
joke that you feel like is better than
the one in there already so then you
said I'm a tape of that and he goes well
maybe that is better so you swap it out
so that changed the whole order again so
now you got to redo the whole five
minutes with that new one in there and
blah blah blah yeah then you just run it
to hell and back so it's second nature
you know but the first time you perform
on Conan you do a joke they told you not
to do that's right why did crowd Porto
Ricans right yeah yeah I said don't do
that joke and I knew I knew in my heart
that a joke would kill and I knew it
would be a better set if I did it and I
did it and it worked
and I and no one said a thing no one
said you piece of [ __ ] that's the thing
about this business is a pic in show
business everybody's scared everybody's
nervous in the industry like the
producers and the show runners they're
all nervous you're gonna say something
offensive say something wrong it's not
gonna work but if it works they don't
mention it they never go oh my god you
lied and you cheated us and you faked us
out they go great job what about if you
do it it doesn't work they hate you and
you're a piece of [ __ ] you get fired
look they had you back every year back
every year and I'm coming back this year
what do you just hit him up now and
you're like hey how about I yeah I go
hey been a year what do you think and
they go yeah yeah send us a tape that's
awesome I mean the tapes have to be up
to par still yeah yeah that's great that
was my goal for 2016 was to get on Conan
oh yeah so that clearly worked it's
never it never this business never goes
the way you think it will yeah I guess
you tape you were in trainwreck but then
got cut out yeah exactly
I mean you do have the burden and the
obstacle of being a straight white man
yes that is true yes a lot of people
don't want to hear that
you know a lot of people at home going
oh [ __ ] you come on but it's true every
meeting I go to now it's like hey we
like your idea but uh we got too many
white guys we had a good run though we
had a great ride like we can't really
complain
well here's the thing is the generation
before us had a great run now we're
getting screwed because of them you know
and then they feel good about slavery
and I'm like wow you know that was
another group yeah
that means this same group but another
other time yeah I don't know the holes
the hole too many white guys is like a
big movement now and I get it there's a
lot of white guys but it's not like
we're sitting at JFK Airport going hey
minority comedian get the hell out of
here there's just a lot of white guys
it's not like we're purposely doing
anything we're not going hey whitey
we're not going to Arkansas and
recruiting white people there's just a
lot of white people what do you want
there's a lot of way people in the
country it seems to be working out for
you though oh yeah I'm not complaining I
mean I guess I am but you know you want
it all as every group does
you know if you cast a Mexican guy in
this role they go oh you only put us in
this role then if you don't cast the
Mexican guy they go you never put us in
any roles they're like a [ __ ] what do I
do
but I'm doing fine and I've had a few
show ideas turned down then I think if I
was Aziz not not that level but if I was
a Indian American or whatever he is I
think I think I might have sold it hmm
but yeah I don't know doing well can't
complain I just all I want to do is tell
jokes for a living and I'm doing that so
I'm happy what kind of shows reap
itching these like sitcoms more like I'm
hosting for sitcoms I've pitched three
game shows three reality shows a pitch a
couple web series
yeah I've been pitching since for like
eight years now and nothing is gone this
is always writing always writing always
gonna have an idea you know some pops in
your head and jot it down send out a one
sheet then somebody goes hey this is
pretty good then you go pitched you make
a pitch packet then you go pitch it and
then they go hey we like it you have a
whole bunch of jokes in the pitch and
then two weeks later they go yeah we're
gonna pass what are they looking for I
mean they're looking for diversity
they're looking for a lot of they want
young they want everything to be young
like you know they're the demographics
that buy [ __ ] are young people like 18
to 24 or whatever so I don't know if I'm
capturing that demo but that's what they
want have you thought about film I know
you went to film school
I thought about film and I've done a few
short films but I since I went to film
school I realize how almost impossible
it is to get a film made a lot of moving
parts yeah and I don't have that kind of
time or patience or money you got to
have a lot of money and people backing
you and like Birbiglia you got to hand
it to him for making two independent
movies that have been somewhat
successful these made money off of it
but people saw mm-hmm and they're pretty
good what did you learn from working
with Judd Apatow oh my god that guy guys
he's uh he's the real deal like he's a
big fat famous guy just a big director
guy and
he's a he's a guy just like this is how
I want it I want you to improvise I want
you to be yourself I want you to be
funny and it's not it's not all about
like I memorized the lines to hell him
back and right when I got there he's
like alright what else you got
I'm like what do you mean what else do I
got I memorized the lines and he's like
yeah but you're riff and I was like oh
my god so then somehow we got into a cut
and he goes everybody go back to your
baby was lunch I went back to my trail I
wrote out like 20 alternative lines I
just was in my trailer just scribbling
away and I got back and I tried them all
he hated all of them and he goes what
else you gotta go [ __ ] and so it was
tough but he's a pro and honor to work
with him yeah I must be a little timid
ating oh very the guy very intimate he's
just so comfortable out there you got
he's in this chair on a swooping crane
you know going over with a big jib and
he's just like eating corn nuts going
alright action what else you got you
suck get out of the way you know it's
quite a quite a moment so you're more
you're not much improv as much as your
word-for-word
that's how you like your stand-up like
just use that as an example like you
don't really improvise much once you
find it you just stick to those notes I
feel like the jokes Todd Barry had a
great quote he said keep the jokes tight
and the set loose and I think that's and
I think that's perfect for me that's
what I do I you know I guy you were at
the show last night yeah you know the
joke I want the joke to be a hundred
percent this way I might change a word
or two here or there but I want that
joked and I wanted to know how it begins
finishes wait wait begin the beginning
middle and end and but then in the
middle of it you can [ __ ] around and I
like that what's the what's the writing
process here what is because you write a
lot so what do you it's not as good as
it should be I I get an idea from start
to finish I get an idea that pops in my
head I jot down that idea then I take it
over into I do an hour of writing every
day about maybe an hour and half an hour
I take it into that and I just play with
it I just walk around my room and just
say it and say this and that and this
guy says if that guy says it how
it's like clay you're kind of like
molding it and squishing it which sounds
incredibly pretentious but you know
you're just [ __ ] around with it and
then something funny happens and then
you write that down
and then something else funny happens
you write that down so eventually you
get like four or five funny lines then
you try it on Stage four out of the five
lines don't work but one does and you
keep that one then you try to get so
you'll just talk through your jokes
you're not really pinned to paper as
much no I'm only pen to paper when I
feel like something clicks and then I'll
write that down just so I don't forget
it but it's all talkie
it's all walkie and talkie yeah I made
that I've tried to do that some but then
I just feel crazy did you have to
overcome feeling crazy just talking to
yourself for an hour totally I mean
there's a point where you feel like
maybe somebody might hear you in another
room then you can all embarrassed then
there's a point where you feel like a
weirdo just talking out loud so you have
to go
alright I'm doing it here we go talking
out loud yeah let's get it over with
alright you have to actually do that
that's why I can't write in Starbucks I
would I would get kicked out I would
look like a lunatic but these guys are
just right sitting down with all these
people around them drinking coffee
walking around I would I can't do it he
is the same like you've written a bunch
of scripts and everything is that the
same process for writing scripts yeah
characters and talking scripts is tough
that's cuz comedy can be so abstract and
weird and all over the place
you can have a joke about dogs and go to
a joke about anal then going to joke
about shoes scripts have to have a
inciting incident and an arc and a plot
to narrative and dialogue and then has
to come together at the end so that that
takes so much more discipline and so
much more of like an outline and a
formula which I'm way bad I'm so bad
with that just the fact I said way bad
and you see in stand-up I could say that
but in the script I'd have to take that
out so it's uh it's tough for me with a
script cuz that's like more of a that's
like an assignment that's homework
comedy is more just let's figure out how
to make this funny and then say it out
loud oh we're done and you're great at
finding like comparisons and contrasts
like I drop a big analogy guy because
yeah I think it analogies that's why I'm
so bad at math I'm horrible at math but
uh I'm a big analogy guy because I don't
think anything conveys a point as well
as an analogy am i have a weird so I'll
throw a weird idea in the audience guys
half but then I throw the analogy yeah
and you go alright now I get it so I
think that's why I do it well your
colbert set you have a joke about how we
can't cure hangovers or we can't prevent
hangovers we can prevent kids yes and
then you take it into how like you're
not honest drunk you're actually honest
when you have a hangover yes like how
did that kind of start and grow into
that that was a weirdo the kids thing
like I always used to say isn't it weird
we can't prevent a hangover number goes
yeah yeah whatever and I'm like oh hang
on this is where the analogy comes in I
go but we can prevent children we figure
that out and people go oh yeah that's
true we can't prevent children but we
can't put a hangover now I see why your
point holds water so I have to throw
that in there just so people go oh I get
where you're coming from now and then
the hangover thing is I'm hungover all
the time and I've always thought people
would say like I know this guy's such a
bad drunk and he's he's got to quit
drinking and I'm like I'm fine drunk I
can drink and drive I can drink and have
a conversation I'm not like a blackout
guy really but when I'm hungover I'm the
I'm a mess and I was like the hey imma I
have a hangover problem not a drinking
problem you know so that that I realized
that then I was like alright well maybe
there's a bit here and then that came
into that so is it like I when I'm
hungover I can't leave the house of my
anxieties through the roof I can't I got
a couch delivered the other day when I
was hungover and I didn't answer the
door so these these movers are at my
home with a couch outside my door
buzzing and I just couldn't do it I
couldn't answer the door because I was
too anxiety riddled I was too [ __ ]
nervous and weird I couldn't do it
so I never got the couch suppose but
it's good to hear you got furniture no
no couch still no couch well with that
with the we can prevent kids but not
hangovers did it start off is we can't
prevent hangovers and then you have you
just tried to riff on a bunch of
different examples and the kids one
stuck or did it immediately the kids one
is is good because
such an extreme you know like I need
something that really like grabs you
like they might say oh we can prevent
termites you're like yeah yeah but
you're like we can prevent kids and then
you think abortion and like what you
think birth control it's it's a it's a
heavier example and I think that's why I
went with it well you find stuff on
stage as well because I mean you were
thinking you were had the most sets of
any new your communion like for a year
right hey I think it's still staying
it's still you know the total I don't
know the total cuz you start trying to
keep track and then you lose it right
yeah it's a whole year but I think I
have the most I got a real problem I
might be losing it now because I do the
road so much and you only do one or two
shows every night in New York yeah and
you're getting to six yeah what a bummer
I'm on the road getting I know yeah
Elena I love the road I get most of my
work done on the road yeah cuz in an
hour set you can try more new like I
said I tried like five new jokes and ii
worked so well were those the race ones
no one was racial one was about being
born gay one was about that Oh what was
about fat cops oh yeah
there's something there there is
something there but yeah but I love how
it it didn't work but you're like
there's just something there
yeah like say it out loud and you got it
I kept talking about it and then one
line hit and I got on my phone so I'm
gonna listen to that today and then see
what that one line is and then go back
and try to sculpt the rest of the joke
around that one line that works
are you disciplined in listening back on
all your sets I'm pretty good but I'm
not as good as I should be
I'll listen a hundred percent for sure
I'll listen if I know there's some
perfect line in there that I need to
keep but if it's just a regular set
where everything worked or whatever then
you go I I already know that if you do
want your old jokes they all work I have
no point in listening to it no boy I
already know that [ __ ] mm-hmm
you're only listening to get some
information are you you do have a lot of
drinks about not drinks you have a lot
about sorry st. Patty's Day yeah that's
right no Irish or whatever
but you do have a lot of jokes about you
know like women and dating and drinking
but I did notice last night you seem
like you're trying to push more of like
having more of a message oh yeah really
I don't want to be that guy we're not
like preachy I mean I know you like
George Carlin was one of your favorite
yeah yeah but he could be preachy at
times and almost like pointing instead
of just like being more just eloquent
about it but I'm I'm making judgments on
what the best committees ever live but
anyway I think the best the best some
people everybody gives it to Pryor and I
think Pryor is a funnier guy and I think
Pryor had a probably the best comedy
special ever
but if pound-for-pound Karlin had 14
Pryor had what five yeah and then he hit
every genre he would do wordplay he
would do topical he would do a society
stuff social commentary puns I feel like
he covered more of a bigger umbrella of
comedy yeah but I think Pryor is a
funnier guy like if he does this YouTube
clip of prior and Carlin on Carson
together
Carlin says three things Pryor is
killing the whole time just off the cuff
yes I think he's quicker funnier but I
think Carlin's a better stand-up comic
yeah he was definitely more methodical
and precise yeah he had his own office
did you know that yeah yeah he had an
office he would report to for writing
say that that's on blue and then he had
this database he had like an old-school
computer and I'm like God jokes you know
sex jokes family and he just had it so
you could go back to his database go
what was that one bit I had on donkeys
and go to his animal animal file you
know crazy how do you organize your
material oh boy well not as well as I
should here I'll show you this is my
jeans and my jeans are on the floor here
I'm pulling out a stack of papers oh gee
you know no book yeah this is it that's
my file cabinet I should I got to
digitize this [ __ ] cuz it's I've
forgotten jokes I've lost jokes in the
washing machine that's just a stack of
papers with notes scribbled on it you
just carry around everywhere everywhere
I go some of those pages are months old
and you haven't looked at them since you
wrote on them no but I'm like oh there's
something on here
and I should remember and I never you
know what I was getting at with the
racial stuff or you you having more of a
message or whatever is that you were
trying to address like race seemed to be
something you were trying to hammer home
and it was in the middle of your set so
I don't know if that's when you were
trying to work out some may be different
yeah it's a view
yeah I'm trying the racial stuff is
actually working but I feel like my act
if you really break it down oh boy we're
getting this is some heavy nerd comedy
[ __ ] here but if you really break my act
down all my premises mostly 90% of them
are about things that people won't
really tell you you know like things
that it's not really appropriate to talk
about you know Adam about appropriate is
the word I'm looking for it it's it's
things where if you brought if you went
up to your aunt and you're like hey aunt
what's up with uh what's up with Jews
she'd be like okay what you get all
weird and then walk away so then I go
well I got here I got to learn about
Jews now cuz she won't so I find that
interesting when we all know these
truths but you can't really talk about
it in certain settings and I think
that's the stuff that interests me the
most and I feel like race is the number
one of those things obviously sex you
know is a big one you can't really like
like [ __ ] you talk about at work that
would get you fired that's the stuff
that interests me because not because
I'm like Luigi but because I want to
know and no one will tell me and I think
race is the number one now you go up to
if you go up to your boss at work and go
Asian people can't drive as a stereotype
is that true and he'll be like ah [ __ ]
what and you're like well is it true or
not and he's like get the hell out of
here what do you do it alright you're
making me feel weird those questions
plague me because I'm like is it true is
it not true and you know yeah I just
start wondering about it so I'm like
well let's let's actually figure out if
it's true you know you go up to a girl
may we're in like fifth grade you go do
you masturbate and they go uh what oh my
god how could you ask me that you're
like well I just want to know do you and
I go oh my god and they never tell you
and that's the whole point of my whole
my whole show I think like I have a joke
in my act where I say this guy was
talking this guy and I go what's the
name with a new guy the black
he goes I don't see color and I'm like
well then I'm black
and he goes no you're not I'm like well
haha you're lied to me so it's like
those things we're like everybody's kind
of full of [ __ ] but you know there's
something there that they won't tell you
that that's my whole act that's what I
want to dig deep into and that's why I
talk about race so much because it's the
number one thing people won't tell you
it was sorry that was a long answer but
I think it was a great answer oh come on
oh it was a great answer mark you're
doing great buddy I appreciate it it had
races definitely you know I'll do a lot
I'll do a lot of urban rooms as well
I'll do like mainstream and urban rooms
and I know you grew up is like the only
white guy where you were yeah any more
than my hood so do you do yet what's
your experience with an urban rooms uh
man I used to do a lot of them I like
them cuz there's an honesty to it you
know there's like is there's more black
folk if we will say that instead of
urban I feel like can they can they have
like a better [ __ ] meter white
people are [ __ ] and all day you know
we like it it's it's easier to deal with
- just take the [ __ ] and then run
with it than it is to face the facts and
so I like the open room because there's
no [ __ ] if I say a buzzword in a
white room there's gonna hear that
buzzword a lot of the time but if I say
a buzzword in a black room they're gonna
go okay what's this point and I like
that I think that's important like I
used to have a joke about black black
people are great cuz they're more honest
than white people like I bought these
new shoes and I was like out of these
shoes corny or these shoes dumb and all
my white friends were like oh they're
fine they're great I like the shoes and
then I bumped into a black teenager on
the subway and he goes watch what you're
going with those corny ass shoes I go I
knew it I knew it
don't tell me except there's one black
teenager so I appreciate that and that's
why urban rooms are great but on the
flip side there are almost too honest
because if you bomb they'll literally
boo you has that happened to you oh my
god I've been booed twice oh let's hear
it
well one there's this room in Harlem
called the mocha lounge and me and my
friend Michael
she's to go up there for kicks which I
guess sounds kind of racist we like
let's go to this black room because
it'll be an adventure and it was it was
in Harlem it was like all black audience
the host was like the blackest man alive
just this guy named smokey smoke Suarez
yes you know smokey yeah holy [ __ ]
that's crazy so we go up once and I I
just I had to set of my ladder I
wouldn't say the set of my life but I
had a good set I was very just in the
moment and like I could tell the
audience was into it and then I had
another set where I got cocky and I
bombed and they booed me and they cut
the mic and it was a whole thing and
then after I got off stage there the
host tore me to pieces you know that was
one you said you've been booed twice ah
there was another time it wasn't wasn't
that cool but I went to wasn't that cool
it wasn't as fun as that story but I
went to this place also in Harlem and
this guy went on stage and did a bunch
of sound effects and I went up after
when I was like I don't know Michael
Winslow was still working and he was
booing me
just by himself so I was getting last
but he was like boo [ __ ] this guy boo
cuz I had made fun of him right and that
was that was it then he came up to me
after he said if you make fun of me
again I'll kill you and I said all right
let's get out of here and then you stop
doing the urban rooms well I stopped
doing the urban rooms because I started
getting regular work yeah you know well
I got a reg up doing a show in Harlem I
think next week so I'm not I'm not I'm
never like a rooms of room I'll never be
like that's an urban room I won't go
I've just I haven't been getting booked
there as much when you were in New
Orleans what was the scene like cuz like
here in Atlanta there there the scene is
somewhat segregated like there's like
there's some rooms that are integrating
but most of it it's like there's white
rooms and there's like black rooms
you're right
so I mean is New York similar uh well
there's definitely both but I think I
think it's pretty open to everyone like
mm-hmm you know if I go up to an urban
room I'll see a white comic there on the
lineup as well you know so I don't think
it's to pardon the pun black and white
but I think there's always gonna be a
little bit of some sort of segregation
yeah that's a bad word but you know
there's always gonna be a little bit of
like well this is the black room as
though
but I think we do a lot we tried
especially now there's a lot more
intermixing because you know people want
a diverse lineup mm-hmm but New Orleans
scene
I mean I member I did the show once it
was totally urban to to the max and I
went on stage and I looked on the side
of the stage and there was a gap between
the stage and the wall and it was full
of stool like broken stools because all
these tools have been humped so many
times a stool graveyard on the floor in
between the stage the wall which I
thought was great because they didn't
clean it up they just pushed it all to
the side when I still would break but
New Orleans scene was pretty I guess
pretty segregated as well but the urban
scene was they were both super small so
you didn't really notice because there
was really no scene anyway so this is
both scenes were so small he didn't
really think about it but now New Worlds
is kind of coming up a little bit but
it's still not a not like I'm gonna make
it here right right right yeah what is
your take on Atlanta scene have you been
able to enter like hang out much here at
all and Lana's not bad you know you got
two clubs right or The Improv closed The
Improv closes supposed to reopen we had
you know the punch line is that done
punch lines open yeah oh great punch one
they just moved okay it moved
punch line with laughing school where
you're at yeah and uptown oh that's
right Atlanta comedy theater oh that's a
lot yeah
all right uh yeah Lana scenes pretty
good um I've done a show here ah where
was it it's in some might have been an
open mic but it's in some bar with the
back as a stage is it 1:00 a.m. show
yeah okay 1:00 a.m. shows Missal bar yes
that was pretty good and then you get to
relapse yeah yes you got a lot of [ __ ]
here yeah that's why we think I mean
that's why I'm still here cuz I would
like to just blow up from here instead
of moving and starting over right my
mind set true but I will say yeah go to
New York or you think in New York or LA
cuz you're a handsome cat yeah you could
probably make some waves in LA like TV
wise but my old focus is being good at
staying okay alright well then I'd go to
New York that that's why I'm still here
is because I can get on you know
here you can get on two or three times a
night so I can get a lot of stage time
here and just get good and then hope
gravity gravitate some sort of
opportunity right right
that's my naive take on comedy yeah yes
no I get it I get it but I will say even
if you go to New York with like a hot
ten minutes you will have to start over
in some fashion because you're new to
everybody so even if you're killing no
one knows you so you got to kill for a
while so they get to know you right yeah
so you're not starting over material
wise you're starting over getting to
know people wise yeah cuz you went to
New York once and moved back right New
Orleans I went to New Orleans cool okay
so then I was doing stand-up at night
like an open mikes and bombing and then
I went back to New Orleans and was
wildly depressed and I didn't know why
it was because I wasn't doing mics
anymore so I started doing open mics in
New Orleans which is like once a week
twice a week maybe and I was like this
isn't enough enough stage time so I
moved to New York did you move back in
with your parents yeah yeah that didn't
help back into the the only white family
in the neighborhood yeah well they had
moved by then cuz OH two guys broke in
with guns and helped my parents up and
so they moved to a better neighborhood
you've been robbed a lot oh my god I
countless times we got robbed right once
every two three months
ruff-ruff never we were that we were
sitting ducks we lived in a mansion in a
poor black neighborhood we were the one
white family so people just assumed we
were killing it but little do they know
that house was dilapidated so I think a
lot of guys would break in and be like
[ __ ] this is it it was like a squat look
at your squatting in there kind of yeah
there was one wing of my dad ran out of
money fixing up the house so he made
half into a bed-and-breakfast so that
half was immaculate and then the half we
lived in was a [ __ ] [ __ ] show what do
they do for a living both lawyers at the
time oh okay one time I walked in on a
robbery I told my parents about it so
they moved their practice into the into
the house because they were like we
can't leave these kids alone in this
neighborhood that's how bad it was how
many siblings do you have older brother
older brother yeah oh wow it's good they
actually they care
I didn't know if they they did they
always let you earn it on your own you
know yeah I guess they did give a [ __ ] a
little bit I mean not enough to move us
out but I think they cared a little I
mean by the time I moved I was in
college like two years later but yeah it
was a rough rough upbringing like I
would hear you'd hear like glass
breaking at night in your house you know
[ __ ] like that
crazy you just ignore it you just have
to put out of your mind we don't alarm
the cops newest who they come over all
the time they were like another Norman's
or getting robbed again yeah we had a
crazy alarm Susan that was like and you
just hear that all the time I know that
sounds so well and he'd hear like 1:00
a.m. I just like pray to God no one
comes in and kills you with a gun you
know what is what does their take you
dropping out of LSU and then going to
film school and then oh I got to move
back home they react
these lawyer parents I think my parents
were pretty cool they were like
ex-hippies okay so they kind of got it
and plus I was I literally had zero
going on in my life I like failed out of
two colleges I got back into one
eventually and I was such a drunk piece
of [ __ ] and I had zero prospects that I
would remember telling my dad I go we'd
go to a restaurant and he'd be like I
happen to be pretty good working here
and he's like what do you do he like
snapped on me what do you do and get a
real job come on you have something work
on it and so I just tried I was such a
loser that I was anything I wanted to
try they were like go for it try
anything you know mm-hmm so I was like
how about film school they're like great
well pay for it go for it and I was like
all right how about stand-up they're
like great go for it so I think they
were it was just like a desperation
thing yeah please make some moves like
I'm gonna go be a janitor let's do that
yeah yeah but that they would have been
like well there's no they wanted
something with a future mm-hmm and which
is how that shows how bad I was off when
they're like stand up try it please
that might work so were you a big
troublemaker oh yeah a big troublemaker
arrested three times for peeing in
public which is weird just a booze bag I
wrecked my dad's Lexus got a DUI you
know [ __ ] like that
it was a it was bad times we we I used
to live in a house with five guys in
college and our whole mission in life
was like we found this this liquor store
that if you brought in three empty keg
shells they would give you a full keg
and we were like well this is our whole
life now so we just drive around Baton
Rouge where I was going to college and
we would just go jump into people's
backyards take their keg go to the back
of a bar where they had keg stacks steal
those we got two fistfights we got
chased we got the cops called on us but
we'd get those kegs and then it was like
a full day's work we'd go turning like
nine kegs shells and get three full kegs
and just keep them in the house
so you've been stealing your whole life
a lot of stealing yeah we I was a big
Street Stein Steeler street sign stealer
hmm and our whole house was just full of
like one-way stop yield you know
slippery when wet and one time we had a
party and the cops came and like broke
it up and they saw the signs they're
like oh you guys are all going to jail
this is like I can this is like hundreds
of thousands of dollars worth of
merchandise or whatever City merchandise
and I remember they had like extra guy
they called for backup for all the
people to take them off the walls
because he weighed so many yeah yeah
it's wild times seems like you're
getting your life together now yeah
things are good now I just needed some
direction that's all which is such a
cliche term but I just needed something
to go towards because I had a lot of
energy but I didn't have anything to put
it into so we would just steal a drink
so what it what is it going towards now
now it's towards right more comedy
trying to do good jokes and be a good
comedian and put out specials and albums
and maybe get on TV and [ __ ] like that
you've opened up for Amy you've opened
up for Louie yeah now as well I mean
what was that experience like ah Louie
was I mean Amy's amazing she changed my
life you know she's given me so much I
have an apartment now in New York cause
of her it's just she's so generous she
gets a bad rap but it's on her all day
long and and I have to like defend her
to people which is so crazy to me
because she's such a good person
and so giving and people say she steals
jokes which is insane I mean she doesn't
really watch a lot of comedy she's so
busy she's not like sitting down going
let me watch this uh you know
Dave Chappelle special from 2001 right
now she's working you know she's writing
a show or being in a movie or writing a
new hour so the whole thing's crazy but
uh you know people that's what we do in
this country we like to just build
somebody up and then rip him down mm-hmm
it's like Ronda Rousey you know she's on
the way up I was like look how great
this female boxer or MMA chick is
killing it oh my god she's a kid like
inspirational quote surprise quoting
yeah and then then she gets knocked out
but it's like [ __ ] her she deserved it
she sucks it's the same with Amy how is
she reacting to it like how does she
handle it she's a tough-as-nails I don't
know how she does it I get one negative
tweet and I get in the fetal position
and cry but she's uh I think she just at
some point realized okay this is gonna
happen and I either got to keep going
and fight it or just crumble and she's
keeping going does that make you a
little apprehensive like would you one
day want to hit her level is that a goal
I don't think I ever want to be that
she's like superstar you know I don't
think I ever want to be that I I'd want
to be like a segura you know something
like that just where you have your fans
you still out a nice show or two and
then you go home and like cigarettes
still walk through an airport you know
mm-hmm who's another guy that you'd want
like Bill burr is almost too big at this
point you know yeah I guess you want
that you want the good life you want the
money but I don't know I think the coz
once you have that Fame you can't really
lose it like John mulaney's a guide like
that's a good level okay yeah so yeah
what was the question
Oh Louie Louie was amazing Louie [ __ ]
Jesus he's you know he's he's the guy I
watched before I even did comedy so to
work with him it's like that Seinfeld
thing he's like I can't believe life is
so long that I'm working with people I
grew up watching you know and yeah just
probably the best comic working today
he's like art Carlin and just edgy and
poignant interesting and an original so
original he's the guy worries about if
this joke has been done to the to a tee
and he's like I've heard jokes like that
so I won't go that way he's just he's
the king and just a humble guy like if
you complement um he gets all
embarassed and he just cares about good
comedy and just sweet guy and very
giving and those shows were amazing and
watching him was amazing so yeah see you
guys sat down and like discuss jokes oh
yeah we would bounce bits cuz jokes are
his whole life that's all that's his
whole thing uh-huh so he would she'd be
like what are you working on what do you
got it's [ __ ] terrifying you go I got
this idea he's like oh that's good but
I'm reading a great note
I had one joke talk about how getting
dizzy is a kid's version of getting
drunk like getting dizzy is that's what
kids you know wine it what he called a
take the take the edge off you know like
I had a rough damn and hit that
merry-go-round blah blah blah silly joke
very you know cutesy but he he was like
me gonna make it personal so now he's
like every joke is funnier if it's
personal so I never forgot that I'm like
alright I gotta remember that every time
I'm writing I go make it personal make
it personal so instead of saying
hangovers are weird I go I was hungover
today you know just make it it goes it
gives it an extra little kick you know
yeah so uh that was great his special
this new special is coming I don't know
when this pod comes out but his new hour
is unreal
yeah unbelievable like he really kicked
it up a notch you you opened up for his
Netflix but yeah right yeah which was a
[ __ ] honor crazy story I I was
sitting in the back of the Comedy Cellar
Lois sitting there and we've hung out I
did Horace and Pete I've worked with him
a few times so I feel like I could talk
to him ah did you hear that she's so uh
we're sitting the back of the Comedy
Cellar
and he goes do you go on in I go I
already went on he goes alright so my
next I was like I don't know where we're
making fun of the comic-con stage he was
a bit of a hack and we're making fun of
him and Louie goes oh [ __ ] you got 20
bucks and I go huh he's got 20 bucks
like oh yeah and I look at my wall I
have 120 in there that's it and like a
moth flew out you guys you got 20 bucks
and he runs out he had a tip a driver or
something he comes back in he goes I'll
pay you back don't worry and I kind of
remember thinking like [ __ ] I was like
my money for the night you know and he's
like I'll pay you back don't worry and
then he does his set gets off stage and
they hand him some money cuz he did a
show or something something happened
where he goes you know what I don't have
any money but you want to do town hall
tomorrow which is like this beautiful
theater in Midtown New York and I was
like yeah of course and he's like I'll
pay you back then so I do town hall and
that was amazing finally opening for
Louie oh my god Town Hall I had a great
set he washed he gave me some notes on
my set and then he goes I'm doing some
other dates if you want to come out I
said yeah and that was that was how I
got this special all for 20 bucks best I
never got the 20 back but is the best
investment I've ever made
paying his way to the top yeah what if I
had a five that gotta had that one 20 in
there you know it's crazy opportunity
it's so cool you're sitting you're
you're sitting in the back of the room
making fun of the comic on stage like
you're at just some open mic whether
that's Louie he's one of us he's just
like a a comic like us and but he's just
older and wiser and better than us
uh-huh at comedy but he's just the same
guy like it's like me and you were
hanging out at Chipotle
that's it's Louie's like that he can
just sit there he gets food on his shirt
he's a you know he makes a joke the
bombs in the table like he's just that
guy normal comedian are there any other
notes or wisdom they you think my
listeners like to hear from him from him
[ __ ] not much he told a lot of great
stories but I can't think of any now boy
I'm on the spot here that's fine I'll
think of it as we go yeah we can come
back to it I also want to ask cuz you've
worked with Judd yes and how was it like
working with Louie in that realm
well Judd was different because it was a
movie it was a big yeah yeah feature
film it wasn't like a lot of one-on-one
you know with judges yeah 80 people
around this lighting guys and grips and
all this jojje is like action try this
try that
you know Judd was tougher but Louie I'm
sitting in a car with him for an hour
I'm sitting on a plane with him for an
hour you know where we got to dinner so
that was a whole different thing mm-hmm
but which is better for me anyway cuz
that I'm wearing a stand up than I am in
movies but yeah Louie I would take
two days with Lily over ten minutes with
Apatow wait that doesn't make sense but
I mean like you run horse and Pete yeah
so him as him as a director rider see
I'm sorry yeah no that was still it was
still cool though man
it was very interesting you're very nice
yeah horse and Pete Louie is way
different like Louie as a director yeah
it's so loose like he'll we'll have a
whole script and he memorized everything
and then he gets there and he goes
forget the script completely like Apatow
is like I want you to riff but there's
still like a structure of some kind
Louie's like if the whole thing changes
he's fine with it I'm talking different
characters adding in an NDA one guy dies
in the middle of it like he'll if it's
funny I'll keep it in so uh also Louie
did a weird thing I don't know if I
should be divulging all this but uh we
would be sitting there and like they're
like all right we got to change the lens
so now we're all sitting at this bar
just kind of like okay well they're
changing a lens it's gonna take ten
minutes what do we do people look at
their phone whatever and Louie would
come up and he would he had a script in
front he would come on just write a draw
a dick on it and then the dick would
shoot jizz on to you in the float in the
drawing and then it'd be alright lens
has changed and then he'd be like got
you so you're laughing then you have to
stop laughing well you know they say
action so there was like little things
like that about Louis like he's just a
regular douchey idiot dumb guy you know
he's way more like he was in the scene
too you know a lot of times so I was
different Apatow is so behind the scenes
yet Horsham Pete was unreal I'm sucking
appetite I mean a Alan Alda called you a
[ __ ] and I'm sitting next to kurt
metzger who's going off about rape
yeah and he's Steven Wright is to my
right you know that was crazy he has a
line and he would say a line differently
and Louise like that's way funnier keep
that and Steven Wright is such a genius
and joke writing and Louie knows that so
he'd be like how can we make this joke
better and see where I go maybe we
should try like this and he'd go perfect
do that so that was fun to watch
and then Buscemi's coolest [ __ ] cheese
very collaborative
very clever yeah almost too
collaborative where you're like I think
it might be
better in the script but [ __ ] it got a
little yeah well I appreciate those
behind the scenes yeah yeah good times
yeah man just what that Louie time it
sees like you know when there's like a
puppy in the room you just were like
alright let me hold the puppy now that's
how Lou excuse me oh I got it boy
yeah you're good we almost made it and
got you choked up talking about Louie
alright yeah what was I saying it's not
the puppy time with no yeah well there's
a puppy in the room you're like [ __ ]
puppy I was just hold the whole time the
same with Louie with Louie's in the room
you're like I don't want to bug him but
you want him to just keep telling you
[ __ ] like I'll listen say it lay it lay
it all on me own thing and but you can't
let him know that you know you can't be
like please tell me more sir well since
you're dying we'll let you all right get
out and relax before your shows this
week weekend at the lavish skull but
before we adjourn yes is there anything
else you want the world to know uh yeah
she's be nice to everybody crazy times
were living in but we'll get through it
and we're gonna look back at this and go
wow that was nuts what a country uh try
to be somewhat fair trying to put
yourself in other people's shoes cuz
right now everybody's me me me my group
my city my gender my race whatever look
at other groups take a load off Jesus
Christ and check out my special May 12th
it's offensive it's gay it's fun
Comedy Central so give it a world comes
out on a Friday May 12 and that should
be fun that's great you're like let's
let's come together me don't be me me me
but my specially
yes that's the world we're living but
it's well deserved it's great to get a
like a behind the scenes look and just
to the all the work that's going in to
the achievements you've had so a lot of
work I'm gonna be right Lance off today
well thank you so much for taking the
time mark Normand thank you and I love
everyone whoo all right
[Music]